pulvérisés dans la nuit par une frappe
russe cet immeuble de la région d'odessa
n'est plus que décombres sur place les
secouristes s'affairent pour évacuer les
victimes un peu plus loin c'est cet
immeuble d'habitation de neuf étages qui
a été touché la structure s'est en
partie effondré selon les autorités
ukrainiennes plusieurs personnes sont
mortes dont des enfants et des dizaines
ont été blessées ces attaques ont touché
la ville de belgorod mister à environ 80
km au sud de desa le grand port
ukrainien sur la mer noire une région
convoitée par moscou qui veut avoir le
contrôle total sur cette mer mais jeudi
les troupes russes ont annoncé s'être
retiré de l'île aux serpents un
territoire stratégique pour le contrôle
du trafic maritime qu'elle avait pris
dès le début du conflit une version
contredite par l'ukraine qui voit le
succès de son artillerie après avoir
échoué à résister aux tirs d'artillerie
au missile et aux frappes aériennes de
l'ukraine l'ennemi les occupants russes
ont quitté l'île aux serpents avec ce
retrait l'emprise militaire de moscou
diminue dans la région mais la zone
largement minet reste dangereuse pour la
navigation pour le crâne et ses alliés
la levée du blocus du port d'odessa
reste une priorité pour faciliter
notamment l'exportation des céréales
sucrées n'y ait
dans le don bas